مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
رياض نبداها بالعنوي
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه يؤكد على تقدم
المفاوضات في اليمن والتوجه نحو شركات
اقتصاديه مع السعوديه
ما احكي لكم قديش انا فخوره انه على الاقل
جاتني هذه الفرصه اني انا اقدر امثل
ان المحطه الدوليه والترقب للحظه انفصال
المركبه عن المحطه
طبيه والحمد لله صحته بخير
تحرير المختطف السعودي في لبنان خضع
لفحوصات طبيه وايقاف التسعه متورطين في
العمليه
في الرابعه
انخفاض كبير للتمويل العقاري للافراد في
السعوديه 43% في ابريل الماضي مقارنه بشهر
مارس
وتفاعل واسع مع فيلم قندهار يتصدر صالات
السينما حول العالم وجارى تصويره في العلا
اهلا بكم نبدا بتطورات الازمه في السودان
نتابع معكم لان احدث ظهور رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان بين
قوته
الله اكبر هو الشعب السوداني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العسكريه مسيطر عليها وكلها بقوتك كامله
الله اكبر نحن
ممكن المسلحه صحيح جهودنا نحن الهدنه دي
قاصدين منها ان الخدمات تمشي لاهلنا الناس
البسطاء المساكين البنات المغتصبا وبيوتهم
حرماتها وماله النهب
قتلوا بدون ذنب بدون ذنب وبدون سبب
يقول الحرب ضد الكيزان
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الشعب السوداني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والله منطقه عسكريه يكون فيها عسكري
سوداني اصيل حي الله
[تصفيق]
قاتل ولاخر جندي حنظل
شهرين
بيقتلوا السودانيين بيجردوا
هكذا وزير الخارج ياتي الايراني حسين امير
عبد الهيان نتطهرن اجرت محادثات غير رسميه
مع الولايات المتحده بشان الملف النووي
واوضح في تصريحاته لصحيفه لوفيجارو
الفرنسيه ان هذه المحادثات تمت عبر وسطاء
من دول المنطقه ودول اوروبيه وشارع عبد
الغني الى انه ابلغ وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان بامكانيات
التنفيذ مشاريع اقتصاديه بشراكه مع
السعوديه كما ان المفاوضات بين الاطراف
اليمنيه تحرز تقدما وان طهران تتواصل مع
جميع الاطراف في اليمن لوقف القتال وذهاب
الى الحوار
معنا من طهران مدير المركز العربي
للدراسات الايرانيه الدكتور محمد صالح
صدقيان دكتور محمد اهلا وسهلا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من هي جميع الاطراف اولا
التي تواصلت مع طيران في الداخل
اليمني كما جاء في تصريحات السيد عبد الحي
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين بالتاكيد يعني
حركه انصار الله هم قريبين من ايران
وبالتالي عندما تريد ايران ان تنسق تنسق
مع مع حكومه صنعاء ومع حركه انصار الله
تحديدا العلاقات بين الجانبين علاقات جيده
والمؤمل ان تستطيع طهران ان تؤثر على
القرار اليمني في صنعاء بشكل الذي يؤدي
الى وقف اطلاق النار ورفع يعني الحصار
المفروض على المطار على الموانئ وعلى
الطرق وبالتالي كما قال حسين امير عبدالله
هيان من اجل فتح باب الحوار اليمني اليمني
وصولا الى تشكيل حكومه يمنيه وطنيه تستطيع
ان تنهي هذه العذابات التي ربما اكثر من
ثمان سنوات الان الشعب الامن اليمني يعني
واقعه تحت هذه الظروف وبالتالي انت تقول
بان
تم بين طهران وبين الاطراف الفاعله في
الداخل اليمني ومنها الحكومه الشرعيه او
المطرق بها الرسميه
يبدو لي بان النصف الاخر وهي الحكومه التي
تفضلت بها
الحكومه الشرعيه المعترف بها رسميا يبدو
بان هذا الامر تكفل به الجانب السعودي
والجانب الايراني تكفل بالحكومه التي هي
في صنعاء وحركه انصار الله تحديدا
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان هناك من خلال
اللقاءات الهاتفيه التي جرت بين وزيره
خارجيه ايران والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
انا اعتقد بان هناك تقدم حدث كانت هناك
زياره اليوم في سعودي الى صنعاء يعتقد بان
هناك
ظروف جديده الان موجوده على الارض وفي
الميدان ويبدو لي من خلال المعلومات التي
يمتلكها يبدو لي بان الامور تسير بشكل جيد
بشكل الذي يؤدي الى وقف اطلاق انا سالت
هذا السؤال حتى استوضح معنى كلمه جميع
الاطراف في اليمن فمعناها بانه هناك طرف
اخر متمثل في الحكومه يعني بان طهران
تواصلت معه من خلال مصادرنا في العربيه وق
هذا اللقاء
داخل مؤسسه الرئاسه تنفي جمله وتفصيلا
وجود اي اتصالات على اي شكل سواء كان
رسميا او ثانوي تم خلال الايام السابقه مع
طهران او ممثلها وان السؤال اذا كانت
السعوديه هي تذهب في مباحثات ومحادثات
مباشره الان مع الحوثيين احد الاطراف
المهمه والذي يعتبر حليف لايران ليس من
الضروري ايضا ان تاخذ نفس الخطوه ايران في
مباحثاتها وفي مفاوضاتها وفي حديثها مع
طرف الحكومه الشرعيه في اليمن اليس الامر
منطقيا
دعني اشير الى ان هناك ثلاثه اطراف حاليا
او اربعه اطراف حاليا تعمل في
وقت اطلاق
وقف اطلاق النار الدائم في اليمن هناك
الجانب السعودي الجانب اليمني الجانب
الايراني والجانب العماني ايضا الذي زار
طهران سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق يوم امس
وهناك الممثليه الامم المتحده وبالتالي
هذه الاطراف هناك مناقشات بين هذه الاطراف
وعندما يتحدث امير حسين عبد الله يعني
يتحدث بانه هناك مع جميع الاطراف ربما
يقصد بان عن طريق الجانب العماني ربما كان
هناك
مباحثات او حوار غير مباشر مع حكومه عدن
وهو كل هذه الاحتمالات وارده لكن في
المجمل اذا راينا في المجمل انا اعتقد بان
كل الاطراف المعنيه حاليا سواء كان
السعوديه وايران وسلطنه عمان وممثل الامين
العام المتحده للسنه اليمني اعتقد بان
جميع هذه الاطراف وبما في ذلك الحكومه
حكومه الائتلاف في عدن وحكومه صنعاء
الحوثيين الكل منغمسين في اطار معين وهذا
الاطار هو كيف ممكن توصل الى موقف اطلاق
النار دائم في اليمن ازاله
الحصار عن جميع المناطق وبالتالي كيفيه
الوصول الى اطار لتشكيل الحكومه اليمنيه
الموحده من خلال الحوار
وما هي طبيعه التفاهمات التي تجري الان
باي شكل الان يمكن القول ان ايران تضغط
ربما اذا جاز لنا وضع هذه هذا التوصيف بين
قوسين تضغط على حلفائها في اليمن نتحدث عن
الحوثيين للوصول الى التفاهمات لانه كل ما
حدث حتى الان سيد صدقيان وحسب الكثير يعني
من المعلومات المتناقله لم يحدث في اي
لقاءات اختراقات حقيقيه لمسار الازمه
اليمنيه وتم تاجيل المباحثات لعدم وجود اي
اتفاق الى ما بعد عيد الفطر كما تتحدث عن
ذلك الانباء
عيد الاضحى يعني قصدك عيد الاضحى نعم لا
توجد هناك معلومات تفصيليه يعني حتى
الزياره التي قام بها سلطان عمان الى
طهران بالتاكيد كانت القضيه اليمنيه
موجوده على طاوله وهناك مباحثات تمت بين
وزير خارجيه البلدين العماني والايراني
وعلى اهم الزياره السلطه سلطان العماني
الى طهران لم تتسرب معلومات تفصيليه عن
هذا الامر لكن بالتاكيد كانت قضيه اليمن
والملف اليمني مطروح على الطاوله لكن بشكل
عام وكما قال السيد عبد الله هيان لصحيفه
فيجارو الفرنسيه يعني هناك هناك مباحثات
وانغماس في هذه المباحثات من اجل التوصل
الى وقف اطلاق النار دائم في اليمن
وبالتالي انا اعتقد بان حتى السلطان نعمان
بحث هذا الامر مع الحكومه الايرانيه وحتى
مع المرشد الايراني له اعلى عندما التق
وانا اعتقد بان ربما حساسيه الموضوع لم
يتسرب او لم يترشح تترشح تفاصيل عن هذا
الموضوع لكن
اكيد هناك انغماس في هذه المباحثات
ايضا
بماذا تفسر سيد صدقيان انه خلال الاسبوع
الماضي خلال الايام القليله الماضيه تظهر
التصريحات وتهديدات من اكثر من طرف من
الحوثيين لاكثر من مكان بتوجيه ضرباته
للسعوديه والامارات ما جاء على لسان مسؤول
مثلا حوثي عندما قال بانهم قادرون على
توجيه ضربه الى القمه العربيه
يعني كيف يمكن تاثير
نعم دعونا لا ننظر الى مثل هذه التصريحات
ننظر الى
الشيء الاهم والقاعده الاهم الاتصالات
التي تتم الهاتفيه بين
فيصل بن فرحان وزير الخارجيه في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه امير عبدالله عيان هذه
الاتصالات الهاتفيه مهمه جدا وهي تتناول
عده مواضيع وانا اعتقد بان مثل هذه
الاتصالات الهاتفيه ربما تريد
ايجاد حل ومخرج ومسار جديد في اليه التوصل
الى اتفاق يمكن التوقيع عليه مع الحوثيين
ومع حكومه صنعاء وانا اعتقد بان التفاصيل
الاخرى هي تفاصيل جزئيه يجب ان لا يعني
تشغل بالنا كثيرا لان هناك قضايا اهم
تسيير ربما تحت الطاوله شكرا جزيلا لكم
دكتور محمد صلاح صدقيان مدير المركز
العربي للدراسات الايرانيه من طهران
رابع بعد قليل
من المره الاولى تدفن مبادره طريق مكه في
تركيا لخدمه الحجار من بلدانهم من المشاعر
المقد
سه
اهلا بكم من جديد انتهت مهمته الفضاء ريان
برناوي وعلى القرني التي استمرت لعشره
ايام في محطه الفضاء الدوليه اجرى خلالها
اجراء اربع عشره تجربه بحثيه علميه في عدد
من التخصصات يغادروا بعد لحظات رائده
الفضاء السعوديان المحطه الدوليه على متن
المركبه الفضائيه دراغون يذكر ان مهمه
الفضائيه انطلقت نحو المحطه الدوليه يوم
الحد والعشرين من مايو الجاري من مركز
كندي للفضاء في فلوريدا متابع معكم هذه
صور المباشره ربما للمراحل الاخيره لمركبه
دراغون قبل انفصالها عن محطه الفضاء
الدوليه وانتهاء مهمتها
وعودتها الى الارض
تقريبا وصلنا لاخر
اخر مراحل هذه المهمه الحمد لله على
التمام الحمد لله اللي قدرنا نوصل لهذا
المحطه ونقدر نخلص ابحاثنا الحمد لله
واجمل لقطات كانت انه قدرنا نتواصل مع
الطلاب ونكون جزء من التاثير اللي حيكون
عليهم باذن الله علميا نطمح باذن الله انه
نشوف رواد فضاء
سعوديين من ابناء الوطن
اجوا هنا ويشتغلوا هنا
ويحاولوا ان هم يخدموا البشريه فهذا يعني
هذا هو الهدف اللي احنا جينا عشانه والحمد
لله انه قدرنا نوصل لهذه المرحله
رسالتي انه حابه فعلا اني اشكر كل الناس
اللي ساعدونا بدايه من مكان اسمه سيدي اخذ
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان
ووليه عهدنا
الرائد والطموح اللي يحمل كل اماننا وكل
افكارنا ورؤيتنا
طبعا لكل قصه نهايه وهذه نهايه الجزء
الاول من هذه القصه الجميله الحمدلله
اليوم اخر يوم لنا في مهمتنا العظيمه
الحمد لله انجزنا جميع المهام الموكله
الينا بنجاح وكذلك تم اجراء وانجاز جميع
التجارب العلميه والابحاث المنوطه في هذه
الرحله بنجاح ولله الحمد وان شاء الله
نسال الله ان تعود علينا بالنفع في
المستقبل وكذلك احب اشكر مقام سيدي خادم
الحرمين الشريفين الملك سلمان بن عبد
العزيز وولي عهده سمو الامير محمد بن
سلمان رئيس مجلس الفضاء على الدعم
اللامحدود الذي نحظى به وحضينا به خلال
هذه الرحله وكذلك احب اشكر جميع الجهات
التي شاركت على انجاح هذه المهمه وكل
العاملين فيها الامانه جهودكم اما الموسى
ودعمكم محسوس فشكرا لكم شكرا لشعبنا
العظيم على على المشاعر اللي شاركتوها
ورايناها منكم
مركز العمليات الموحد في داخل مقريات
الفضاء في الرياض انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه
الان من مراحل التي ستتم بعد بدايه عمليه
انفصال المركبه عن محطه الفضاء الدوليه
وصولا بعد ذلك الى الارض
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بمشاهدي قناه العربيه
اذا من داخل مركز عمليات الموحد هنا في
هيئه الاتصالات
والتقنيه والفضاء والتقنيه
نرصد لكم المرحله الاخيره واللحظات
الاخيره تحديدا من انفصال المركبه عن محطه
الفضاء الدوليه لكن في هذه اللحظات ما
زلنا ايضا وكما يتابعها الساده المشاهدين
الان صعود رائدي الفضاء وكذلك او رواد
الفضاون بينهم ايضا رايدي الفضاء ريان
وعلي على متن هذه المركبه طبعا هناك مراحل
عده سوف يمر بها او سوف تمر بها المركبه
حتى الوصول الى الارض هذه المراحل سوف
نشرحها او يشرحها معنى ضيفي الدكتور هيثم
التويجري وهو المستشار هنا في هيئه
الاتصالات والفضاء والتعليم مرحبا بك
دكتور هيثم على شاشه العربيه كما
ويشاهد مشاهدي قناه العربيه صعود
رواد الفضاء وراء ايديه الفضاء تحديدا
ايضا ريان وعلي على مركبه
في البدايه ارحب بالمشاهدين الكرام ارحب
فيك وانا اخوك
اللي نراها الان هذه المراحل الاخيره
لانفصال محطه
الفضاء الدوليه عن
زي ما تفضلت وهذه تتطلب عده اشياء اولا
فيه مراحل
تكون فيها المركبه
زي ما تقول في طور التجربه عندهم يرون ان
كل شيء ملائم بحيث انه يكون الانفصال كامل
اغلاق الابواب اغلاق يعني
الصمامات كل شيء يكون متلاعب من الزيت
وكذلك الخوذه وايضا زي الفضاء الذي
يلبسونه تحديدا
الان هذا زي ملائم للبس داخل المركبه
غير ملائم طبعا
لخروج المركبات لكن هذا اللي يلبسونه هو
يتغطون فيه ويكون فيه
[موسيقى]
الكامل مغطيهم وحافظهم يعني خلينا نتكلم
عن المرحله التاليه المركبه منذ انطلاق
هاي خلال تقريبا بعد ساعه سوف تبدا مرحله
الانطلاق حتى تصل الارض خلال ثلاثين ساعه
او على
الساعات التي قد تصل اليها حتى تصل الارض
بعد 30 ساعه وهناك مرحله حرجه ايضا يمرون
فيها تصل سرعه المركبه الى اكثر من 28 الف
كيلو متر في الساعه ودرجه حراره الى اكثر
من
صحيح طال عمرك طبعا هم الان على تقريبا
ارتفاع 400 كيلو متر من فوق السطح الارض
فالان يقومون
بمناورات بحيث انهم يخبطون في ارتفاع الا
ان
يدخلون الى تقريبا اغلاء في الجوي لما
يدخلون الغلاف الجوي زي ما تفضلت طبعا
السرعه الفائقه اللي هم داخلين فيها راح
تسبب احتكاك عظيم وهذا سبب شكل الكبسوله
اوكي يعني سبحان الله زي دمعه العين
بذلك يعني نعم هي هي سبحان الله العلماء
عرفاها من جامعه العين وكيف تنزل فبالتالي
الان
الكبسوله المصممه بحيث يدخلون وزي ما
تفضلت بيدخلون عبر الغلاف الجوي بسرعه
عاليه جدا يمرون في يعني
اشاره عاليه جدا
والسرعه عاليه جدا وكذلك يعني فقدان
للاتصال ما بين مركز التحكم وبينهم نقف
عند هذه النقطه ست دقائق يفقد الاتصال بين
هذه الكبسوله المركبه وبين هذه الفضاء الا
ترى يعني من خلال
ما علمتوه من محطه الفضاء الدوليه وايضا
قبل انطلاقهم ان هذه هي المرحله قد تكون
خطره او ما تسمى خطره مثلا هي منطقه يعني
[موسيقى]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني ما نبغى نقول
خطره لكن هي منطقه يعني حينما ما ما نتصل
فيهم لكن هم ان شاء الله بيكونوا بخير
يمرون خلالها وبعدين يتجاوزونها وافضل شيء
يكون عندما الكاب كوم يرد عليهم ويقول كاب
كما تحدث انها في هذه اللحظات الان يقوم
ردي الفضاء ريان اوريك وذلك الفضاء
الاخرين الذين
يصعدون جميعهم على هذه الكبسوله بتحضير
النهائي كما نشاهد الان هم يتابعون بعض
التعليمات في من خلال التاب الذين يحملونه
وكذلك بعض التعليمات التي الان يتلقونها
من فلوريدا حول عمليه الانفصال وكذلك
عمليه المراحل التي سوف يواجهونها اثناء
وصولهم الى الارض شكرا لكم هاني سنعود
اليكم ربما لمتابعه يعني لحظه انطلاق
المركبه دراغون خلال هذه النشره شكرا لك
مره اخرى
اكد وزير الداخليه اللبنانيه بسام مولوي
ان عمليه التحرير المواطن السعودي جرت
بتنسيق بين كل الاجهزه الامنيه اشارى خلال
مؤتمر انسحابي المشترك مع السفير السعودي
في بيروت انه تم توقيف التسعه متورطين في
حادثه الاختطاف لدى مخابرات الجيش
اللبناني الجيش اللبناني قام بعمليه
بعمليات تفتيش وبحث في البقاع في البقاع
الشمالي تحديدا وحتى الحدود
الحمد لله بتنسيق كل الاجهزه الامنيه تم
الوصول الى النتيجه السعيده النتيجه
المرجوه وهو تحرير المواطن الشقيق المواطن
السعودي الشقيق نحن عنا اليوم تسعه
موقوفين تسعه موقوفين موجودين لدى مخابرات
الجيش
بنتيجه هاي العمليه وبسببها
لبنان وليد البخاري انا المواطن السعودي
مشاري المطيري بخير وخضع للفحوصات الطبيه
اللازمه واكد البخاري حرص القياده
السعوديه على سلامه المواطن السعودي اينما
وجد
احب ان اؤكد بانه المواطن السعودي
لفحوصات طبيه والحمد لله صحته بخير نطمان
كل ذويه بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه
واصدقائه ومحبيه حرص القياده السعوديه حرص
خادم الحرمين الشريفين
والسرور سيدي ولي العهد على المواطن
السعودي اينما وجد هي اولويه من اولياتها
اولويات المملكه
للمره الاولى السعوديه اليوم مبادره طريق
مكه في تركيا في الصاله المخصصه في مطار
اسطنبول بحضور مدير عام الجوازات السعوديه
ورئيس هيئه الشؤون الدينيه التركيه التي
تنفيذه مبادره طريق مكه للعام الخامس
باشرافي وزاره الداخليه السعوديه في سبع
دول وهي احدى مبادره برنامج خدمه ضيوف
الرحمن احد برامج رؤيه السعوديه 2030 تهدف
المبادره الى استقبال الحجاج وانهاء
اجراءاتهم من بلدانهم بسهوله ليتم
انتقالهم عند الوصول مباشره الى اماكن
اقامتهم لمكه المكرمه والمدينه المنوره
رابع ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل انخفاض
كبير للتمويل العقاري للافراد في السعوديه
43 في المئه في ابريل الماضي مقارنه بشهر
مارس
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه يؤكدها على تقدم
المفاوضات في اليمن والتوجه نحو شركات
اقتصاديه مع السعودي
ما احكي لكم قديش انا فخوره انه على الاقل
جاتني هذه الفرصه اللي انا اقدر رايدها
الفضاء ريان وعلي يودعان المحطه الدوليه
وترقب للحظه انفصال المركبه عن المحطه
لفحوصات طبيه والحمد لله صحته بخير نطمان
تحرير المختطف في السعوديه في لبنان خاضع
لفحوصات طبيه وايقاف تسعه متورطين في
العمليه
انخفاض كبير للتمويل العقاري للافراد في
السعوديه 43 في المئه في ابريل الماضي
مقارنه بشهر مارس
التفاعل واسع مع فيلم
يتصدر صلاه السينما حول العالم وجرى
تصويره في العلا
اهلا بكم منذ التاسعه من فبراير الماضي
وتحديدا في مؤتمر الليب تقني بدات هياته
الحكومه الرقميه في السعوديه تقييم واقعي
وجاهزيه التقنيات الناشئه في الجهه
الحكوميه زميله شاهد المتروك تعرفنا على
تلك التقنيه وعلاقتها بالخدمات التي قد
نحتاجها يوما
تقنيات لم تبلغ مرحله التطور الكامل ابسط
تعريفا للتقنيات الناشئه السعوديه بدات في
فبراير الماضي بتقييم تلك التقنيات في
الجهات الحكوميه وما تقدم من منتجات
وخدمات وتوصلت عمليات التقييم الى جاهزيه
الجهات الحكوميه في السعوديه الى تبني
التقنيات الناشئه بنسبه تتجاوز الستين في
المئه لكن كيف تستخدم التقنيات الناشئه في
الخدمات الحكوميه في القطاع العدلي مثلا
هناك مشروع التنبؤ بالاحكام القضائيه وفقا
للمعطيات ما يعني سرعه في التقاضي واصدار
الاحكام هذا المشروع استفاد منه حتى الان
الف مستفيد و2700 قاضن في مختلف مناطق
السعوديه وفقا لتقرير صادر من هيئه
الحكومه الرقميه
مستشفى صح الافتراضي من ابرز الشواهد على
استخدام التقنيات الناشئه في الخدمات
الحكوميه يخدموا اكثر من 400 الف مستفيد
سنويا عبر 152 مستشفى ويقدم خدمات
افتراضيه لرعايه وتشخيص المستفيدين صحيا
عند ارتيادك عزيزي المشاهد لطريق ما في
السعوديه قد تصلك رسائل تحذيريه حول اعمال
صيانه او حادث لا قدر الله هذه الرسائل من
ملامح التقنيات الناشئه التي تستخدم
لتسهيل حياتنا
انخفاض كبير سجله البنك المركزي السعودي
في حجم التمويل العقاري السكني الجديد
المقدم للافراد من المصارف خلال الشهر
الماضي حيث انخفض من نسبه 55% مقارنه بنفس
الفتره من العمل
اتى ايضا بشهر مارس الماضي فقد شهد
التمويل
في الاستوديو ينضم الينا الخبير والمطور
العقاري ماجد العرابي الحاتي سيد مجد
هذا الانخفاض
بهالوين انخفاض قياسي كبير مقلق كيف يمكن
توصيف
والله اكيد من دور ارتفاع الفائده في
البنك الفيدرالي وكنا نتنبا انه بيكون
هناك انخفاض طبعا في الطلب على العقار
لانه ارتفاع البنك الفيدرالي مؤثر على
القطاع العقاري في كل انحاء العالم
كون ان البنوك المحليه مرتبطه بالبنك
المركزي وبالتالي في ارتفاع الفائده يؤثر
في عمليه ارتفاع قيمه القرض
فائده القرض وبالتالي تقليص قيمه
القرض فهناك لا يمكن
للمواطن
القرض الذي يسرق له من البنك شراء وحده
سكنيه موافقه في سوق العقاري لان اليوم
السوق يشهد ارتفاع اسعار في اسعار
الوحدات السكنيه مقابل ارتفاع فائده في في
البنوك وش الحل في مثل هذه الحاله لانه
كمان متوقع
هتكون في الزياده يعني في الفائده يعني
خلال من خلال التوقعات ايضا في البنك
الفيدرالي خلال الفتره القادمه بالتالي
فالمعدل سيتم زياده هذا هو اللي شفت انا
امس تقرير انه ما زال مصرين انه خلال
سنتين القادمه يظل مرتفع لتقليل من التضخم
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وبالتالي
سيؤثر على
الدول المرتبطه بالدولار
فهناك اشكاليه اما انه تنخفض الفائده من
خلال البنك الفيدرالي وارتباطنا به او
انخفاض الوحدات السكنيه اسعارها في السوق
السعودي واليوم شاهدنا انه في في حراك مع
المطورين في ليونه في عمليه
المفاوضات وجود هدايا ووجود
يعني مغريات للمشتري لربما انه يعني
يحركون السوق شوي طب اذا استمرت هذه
المشكله نعم وين وين تتجه الازمه برايك
وهل يمكن ان يكون هناك حل لا بد يكون هناك
انخفاض في الاسعار
ان لم يكن هناك انخفاض في اسعار الفائده
فلابد يكون هناك انخفاض في اشعار العقار
لتوافق القيم القدره الشرائيه للمواطن
تلمس انه في هناك انخفاض في الاسعار في
العقاري يلائم حجم الارتفاع في الفائده
الازمه لجلسه تحصل مقارنه بدول اخرى يعني
مثلا على سبيل المثال يقارنوا في امريكا
ان هناك انخفاض كبير في اسعار العقار
بالنظر الى التغيرات اللي حاصله في
الاسعار الفائده يمكن احنا في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ممتاز ان هناك في حمايه
للمواطن في
انه القروض العقاريه بالذات ما تتبع البنك
او تتبع الفائده اللي تكلمنا الشبرالي في
ارتفاع وانخفاض الفائده فهي مثبته الى
عشرين سنه تقريبا فهذه واحده من ضمن
الامان بالنسبه للناس اللي اقترضوا
وانتهوا
في امان يعني باذن الله لكن المفترض
الجديد لا يصبح القرض اللي بياخذه مثلا
بياخذ مليون البنك بيحسب عليه سبع مئه الف
فاصبح القيمه عاليه جدا نعم فائده عاليه
جدا وايضا قللت القيمه القرض اذا كان
البنك يعطيك مليونين اصبح الان يعطيك
القرض مليون فما تقدر تشتري وحده سكنيه من
السوق هنا اليوم في تغير حتى في المطور
العقاري اصبح
يستهدف الشريحه الاقل سعرا واليوم الحمد
لله يعني الشركه الوطنيه قاعدين نشوفها
تقدم خدمات جيده من خلال الاسعار اللي
قدمتها في الضاحيتين اللي قدمها
قدمتها وزاره الاسكان فرسان
وتناسب هل في انخفاض في اسعار العقار
[موسيقى]
الركود وين ممكن يوصل وهل ممكن ينسحب على
احنا نتكلم عن القطاع السكني فقط
قطاعه الثانيه
ليست له علاقه بالقروض ولا
فالقطاع السكني اكيد لابد اجباري انه
ينخفض ان لم تنخفض
الفائده اليوم قاعدين حتى شفت في التقرير
اللي قدمته
الامس انه في ايضا انه وصلت المستهدفات
وزاره الاسكان الى تقريبا
يعني قربت الى تقريبا 67% يعني قربت
المستهدف اللي هو 70% اللي بيكون في عشرين
ثلاثين وهذا واحد من ضمن الجوانب اللي
الحمد لله يعني قدمت فيها الوزاره شوط
كبير
فالاجباري هنا لابد ان يكون فيه انخفاض في
في الاسعار
يعطيك العافيه
لخالتي الخبير المطور العقاري شكرا جزيلا
لك
حضورهم كبير لفيلم على شاشه السينما
العالميه واول فيلم عالمي يتم تصويره
وتنفيذه في السعوديه تحديدا في محافظه
العلماء الفيلم من بطوله باتلر وبدا عرضه
في الصلاه الخميس الماضي يحكي عن الصراع
الاستخبارات بين الاجهزه الامريكيه
والبريطانيه والايرانيه والباكستانيه
تناول الوقائع حديثه منها تفجير معمل
نتاليز واغتيال المشرف على البرنامج
النووي الايراني علي فخري زيدان
[موسيقى]
نعم خالد مازلنا نتابع عمليه التواصل بين
الرياض وفلوريدا وايضا التعليمات التي
يتلقاها هنا فنيون ومهندسونا من هيئه
الاتصالات والتقنيه والفضاء من خلال
المعلومات الاخيره التي سوف ينفذها رواد
الفضاء من بينهم رايدين الفضاء ريانه وعلي
من المركبه دراغون وكذلك من خلال
التعليمات الاخيره التي يتخذونه والتي يجب
تنفيذها حتى يصلون الى الارض السالمين
طبعا سوف اعود الى ضيفي مره اخرى وما زلنا
نتابع هذه الصور ولكنها لعل هذه الصوره
الان نشاهد ايضا غرفه العمليات الموحده
هناك في فلوريدا وكيف ايضا عمليه التواصل
بين الرياض وفلوريدا في العمليات التقنيه
ونتحدث عن هذه عمليات التقنيه من خلال
سواء المعلومات التي كما ذكرت في بدايه
الحديث من خلال ما ينفذه عمليه التنفيذ
التي سوف تتم الانفصال المركبه دراجون من
محطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك هنا في الرياض
من خلال الفنين والمهندسين الذين يقومون
بتحليل هذه المعلومات وكذلك متابعه
هذه الارقام طبعا هناك بيانات كثيره ورموز
عديده وهي رموز فضائيه بين الرياض
وفلوريدا من اجل سلامه المركبه وصولها الى
الرياض ضيف من جديد الدكتور هيثم التويجري
وهو مستشار في الهيئه مرحبا بك مجددا يعني
كنا نتكلم الان صوره كما نشاهد الان من
فلوريدا وهنا في الرياض كيف تتم هذه
العمليه ما الذي يحدث الان في هذه اللحظات
بين مركز اتصال الموحد في فلوريدا وبين
مركز اتصال موحد نتواجد في داخله في
الرياض في البدايه يعني اشكركم لكن يعني
لما ننظر الى هذه الصور احنا ننظر الى
مركبه كرودن اثناء انفصالها من محطه
الفضاء الدوديه وهذه تت خطوات لان محطه
الفضاء الدوليه
يعني حولها ما يعتبر
[موسيقى]
سفير اوكي وهمي ببعد 220 متر كيف تبتعد
عنه وبعدين كذا ثم تاخذ المناورات للتبطئه
من سرعتها بحيث انها تقدر تنزل من
الارتفاع اللي هو تقريبا 420 400 كيلو الى
ان تدخل الى الغلاف الجوي وساعتها زي ما
تفضلت ندخل في الساعات الحرجه بعد عده
ساعات من
تباطؤها الى الهبوط ودخولها في الغلاف
الجوي وساعتها نرى يعني احرج الساعات او
الدقائق
ثمان او ست الى ثمان دقائق
ينقطع فيها الاتصال بحيث انه يعني
الافراد اللي موجودين على المركبه لا
يستطيعون انهم يكونون على اتصال مع الارض
ساعود اليك وسوف ادعك من حديثك ولكن هنا
مركز التحكم في عمليه الانفصال هل هي من
محطه الفضاء من المركبه ام من محطه
فلوريدا في الارض
في طبعا في المهمه هذه في ثلاث محطات في
محطه هيوستن اللي تابعه لنا في محطه اكسيم
وكذلك في محطه
اللي فيه
ثلاث محطات تتم تتابع
الكبسوله انفصال المركبه انفصال المركبه
يتم تلقائيا لانه عمليه مبرمجه يعني
يقوم بها الطاقم بناء على اجراءات محدده
فبالتالي
الانفصال ان شاء الله
لن يكون فيه اي عبء لكن يعني العب الكبير
ان شاء الله والله يرجعهم سالمين غانمين
الى
الارض وبعدين من ثم الى ارض الوطن يعني
الصور تتنقل او تنتقل بين صور من بوابه
المركبه وداخل محطه الطاقه هناك وايضا بين
صور داخل للرواد الفضاء وكذلك نرى ريان او
علي الان وهم
يعني مستعدون لانفصال هذه المركبه وكذلك
واضح جدا ان اتبعوا التعليمات والارشادات
خاصه بعد توقفهم عن القراءه بالتاب دعنا
ايضا نطرح السؤال الاخر انت تحدثت عن ان
المرحله الحرجه وذكرت في النشره او قبل
قليل اننا نذكرها بالمرحله الخطره
هل قد يحدث او او قد يكون وضع الامان في
هذه المرحله الحرجه نسبه عاليه جدا من
كونها ننطقها مرحله حرجه ولله الحمد يعني
تم تصميم المركبه الطريقه انها تكون
مناسبه وملائمه لاختراق الغلاف الجوي وهذا
تصميم يعني سبحان الله يعني يعود الى قطره
العين يعني الدمعه لو تشوف شكل القطره وهي
تسقط وهذا اللي تم بناء عليه تصميم
المراكب اللي تخترق
الغلاف الجوي لا هذا سلمك الله من يعني
الستينات وهم جربوه واستخدموه فان شاء
الله يعني ما في خوف والاخير البحوث التي
تم اجرائها من قبل ريانه وعلي هل نجحت هل
كانت عمليات التطبيق ناجحه
اكبر نجاح سلمك الله كان هو التواصل مع
اطفالنا
والطلبات في المدارس كيف انهم كانوا هم
معلمين كل ما يدور في هذه المهمه وهذا كان
اكبر نجاح ان ناهل الجيل القادم ان شاء
الله شكرا لك دكتور هيثم اذا كان هذا حديث
الدكتور هيثم التويجري وهو مستشار في هيئه
الفضاء والاتصالات والتقنيه هنا ومازلنا
نتابع ايضا هذه الصوره الان التي
تشاهدونها الان من هنا من مركز الموحده
عمليه الموحد هنا في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض وتحديدا من داخل الهيئه لعمليه
دخول المركبات وكذلك بعض في محطه الطاقه
في الفضاء في متابعه عمليه انفصال شكرا
العمليات الموحد في هيئه
العناوين
وزير الخارجيه الايراني يؤكدوا على تقدم
المفاوضات في اليمن والتوجه نحو شركات
اقتصاديه مع السعوديه
رايده الفضاء ريان وعلي والدعاء المحطه
الدوليه والترقبوا للحظه انفصال المركبه
عن المحطه
تحرير المختطف السعودي في لبنان خاضعه
لفحوصات طبيه وايقاف وتسعه متورطين في
العمليه
انخفاض كبير للتمويل العقاري للافراد في
السعوديه 43% في ابريل الماضي مقارنه بشار
مارس
والتفاعل واسع مع فيلم قندهار يتصدر صلاه
السينما حول العالم والتصويره كما في
العلا
لذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات